une course contre la montre avec 43
mille morts et 1,4 million de
contamination le temps presse pour ce
pays de plus de 57 millions d'habitants
ce sont plus de 500 décès qui sont
dénombrés chaque jour ces dernières
semaines alors face à d'urgence pretoria
a décidé de ne rien attendre du
dispositif kovacs de l' oms et d'acheter
ses propres 12
si l'on devait rédiger un tome sur la
lutte durable du pays contre la pandémie
de kovy de 19 lundi marquerait un
nouveau chapitre celui de l'anticipation
de l'espoir et des possibilités 1
millions de doses sont attendus ce lundi
en afrique du sud
il s'agit du vaccin aux forces
astrazeneca produit par l'institut sérum
en inde
cent cinq mille doses supplémentaires
sont attendus d'ici fin février la
campagne va débuter par le personnel de
santé 1,2 million de personnes
puis suivront 40 millions de sud
africains l'objectif une immunisation de
groupe avant la fin 2021
mais la vaccination dans les pays riches
a pris une sinon deux longueurs d'avancé
la semaine dernière lors du forum
économique mondial de davos le président
cyril ramaphosa avait dénoncé le manque
de solidarité des pays les plus fortunés
nous sommes préoccupés par le
nationalisme vaccinale les pays riches
sont allés acheter beaucoup de doses de
vaccins auprès des concepteurs et des
fabricants de ces vaccins certains pays
sont même allés au delà et ont acquis
jusqu'à quatre fois ce dont leur
population a besoin
cela visait à stocker ces vaccins
maintenant cela amène à l'exclusion des
pays qui en ont le plus besoin
vendredi le directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
avait réagi en appelant au partage des
doses nous demandons aux gouvernements
qui ont déjà reçu des livraisons de
vacciner leurs agents de santé et les
personnes âgées puis de partager les
doses excédentaires avec le kovacs afin
que d'autres pays puissent faire de même
un plaidoyer pour une distribution plus
équitable du vaccin
alors que la pandémie a déjà fait plus
de 2,17 millions de morts dans le monde